hello and welcome to video playing
Russian and let's see if I can try Miami
Roxy behind idea now they all play a
regular dragon and again if he goes
deform k doesn't yeah so we basically
get a cop or system with colors reversed
coming from c-45 just culture with age
three now yeah very solid play III be
fine k 6p 5p link is stopping it
[Music]
play 45 I wonder if he can play
beautiful here actually yeah but I have
this 5 it should not be bad
white Bishop doesn't have all that many
great squares yeah here I was thinking
that maybe 94 as an option what's
impressive form okay let's go see form
gain some space
maybe a 4g fools are no we take sent
that didn't expect I don't know b3c
trying to take my pawns there I am
[Music]
dad do i take mm-hmm probably I can also
allow him to take and I don't know if
that is so bad my pork looks still quite
ok them and I have we ate before
they probably won't take okay but i have
looked before next
[Music]
might be hot blonde as a pawn ok I think
I took this but now let the five is
possible right
I asked impartiality for if the night is
taking
okay it just looks at the a pawn here
okay so hold we cover it yeah a four is
hanging don't see it really is then
don't see a pic addition any sect
exchange or something now so I go here
or I can also check and take C 3 for the
default hanging well yes that's helpful
should be five very likely
I have an a porn so the thing is what
was now G 523 isn't so convincing he
does have come here just have some
counter play it's not like there is
absolutely nothing t Queen f7 Osric g8
okay i go here so then at least I can
prevent the Queen e5 check
threatening we should be five now we
should be five point X now I'm not
threatening is really fun well I'm
threatening to wonder okay but I don't
think this works I take it to settle and
then check for me there what okay well
team and check on this seven okay okay
if I go up behind more linking and we
have to go here
his bishop is not doing much in the
attacker at least not right now should
reform just trying to take them not so
easy
check
okay I'm coordinated right enough here
we should be aight i can go back you
cannot cover yeah everything now check
check check check check he was there
damn slice me that Tucker was looks
pretty tough at the end here and yeah I
think he must be must be okay I'm for
both of us shouldn't be anything great
ikea nine to five and then somehow that
got lost there a fault or not got lost
it should take these five no that's not
a move that I thought about but ok this
isn't bad either Jesus can
sir that I am better candidate and it's
just not enough IAM you'll be six
ultimately project probably losing a g5
I thought about that move but didn't
feel so convincing ok so now and instead
of this Kleenex Evan was possible route
eight and this was wow that would have
been very awkward to play
a computer finds a slight advantage I
wonder what that means in this position
shoot eggs now I can forget about that
no human players ever going to find that
with black that that probably wouldn't
have ended well okay do you think
relatively easy to defend yes what did I
did I blunder some somewhere i'm saying
i hope i didn't and ce3 was pretty easy
now okay I was panicking a little bit
with retirement yeah bondage is so great
that you cannot screw it up ok guys
thanks for watching